I have been taking my son to a naturopath for several years trying to detox heavy metals.
We've done so many protocols but his heavy metal tests still show high.
What is wrong? So first of all there's how do you measure if a person's got heavy metal toxicity?
There's really two different tests to do. There's a hair analysis test where you take a hair sample
you send that in and they test for heavy metals or there's a provocation test where you take a bunch of key
laders, you kind of OD on key laders which pulls a whole bunch of stuff out of your tissues
into the bloodstream and hopefully you'll excrete more and then you do a 24-hour urine test and you
measure the heavy metals in that 24-hour urine sample. Now the issue that I have I have issues with both
those tests, number one, the hair analysis test is not super accurate. Again, no test is going to be
perfect. The provocation test I have it with more issues with it because you could actually make
a person sick because they're not going to be able to excrete all those heavy metals and it's just
going to circulate and be deposited somewhere else and cause more issues. So I don't like either one of
those tests if I had to choose one, I would do the hair analysis test. Order that on our store if you're
a course member. But the truth is that we all have heavy metals. So do we need to do the heavy metal
hair analysis test? I don't think it's a need to do test. You can assume that a person has it.
So what to get to the answer to this question, what is this person doing wrong if they're doing
different protocols? Well, I don't know what kind of protocols this person is doing but many times
you'll go to an etcher path get tested for heavy metals and they'll go right to what are called key
laders. So key laders are things that grab onto stuff in the cells or in the tissues and bring it back
to the blood. So it circulates through the blood in the hopes that you're going to detoxify it.
Now you're going to get rid of it. The end point of detoxification remember is toilet. So the problem
is is I call that phase zero when you're key lading stuff out of the tissue. You have six other phases
that you have to do first prior to that. Many times when people aren't able to detoxify quickly
they could be labeled historically they're labeled slower detoxers. It's because they have issues
with most commonly with phase one phase two detox pathways that the liver had most
commonly to that they the issues are genetic. So if you have genetic defects on your cytochrome P450
or your punt pathways, you're at a tea pathways, you're going to have slower detox ability. So
and then the liver is going to get clogged quickly. There's other reasons too. A person can have a
overwhelmed liver because a whole bunch of different things. But those are that is the probably the
most common traffic jam that we have in the whole detox pathways. So I would highly suggest that
you go get our course for 50 bucks on the six on the seven phases of detoxification and start going
through that. You have to go through all these phases of detoxification. You really have in my opinion
you have no business to each elation and tell you dealt with these other six pages of phases of
detoxification. Also getting genetics done would be a good thing to look at too.